hello there reject nation I'm Greg Alba
I'm John Humphrey we are going to watch
from corridor crew VFX artists react to
bad and great CGI is it batting great
yes right this is number five I think
I've seen one of these before definitely
not this one I would recognize it from
the thumbnail love these guys
top rewards your request remand named
Cameron French let's get into this
[Music]
welcome to VFX artists react to bad and
great CGI we applaud the genius of a
good effects and blame the iPhone
compositing get iPhone app claws in your
hands first off yeah the tracking on his
right hand ever so slightly oh yes
it's a harnessing kramer frame but in
motion it just doesn't feel attachment
even more so there's no freaking shadow
on his knuckles yeah well you got these
just like the CG model sticking out of
his hand they don't even have proper
motion blur highlights and this either
like notice when the motion blur is on
the bright parts of the blade the bright
part gets dimmer whereas that bright
much should be bright enough to
selectively metal that it stays bright
imagine my flashlight is a bright part
of a blade I go like this it doesn't
turn great it stays like that they
probably didn't have a proper HDI for
the scene basically capturing the proper
lighting of the scene but also
recreating the materials in a very
scientifically accurate way idiot
the biggest question is why aren't they
practice special type of blade holder
that's like literally just hold your
fists
[Music]
do you recognize film lots of scenes
here including we've seen your comments
and if you'd like to see other movies TV
shows anything at all for us to react to
please leave a comment below just mr.
clean I think it's just an example of
like they're probably going in and
taking all the wrinkles and doing some
patch work on his face but in doing so
they're not staying quite trying true to
the lighting sometimes there's
footprints there leaving footprints on
they run why are they leaving footprints
and not even having a shadow at least a
fuzzy soft dark matte and you need their
feet oh this movie at the same budget is
transformers and this is the quality of
education this is the like the last
stage of art it's just eyeballing it I
guess this is like yeah went out there
got like light meter readings and I took
my photo samples
pri and I have a scientifically accurate
and agenda moment for what that should
look like transformers looks so good
yeah because that's what they did for
all the Transformers everything was
physically accurate measured with HDR
eyes proper service simulations yeah
transformers finally getting the respect
that bus is real that explosion is real
that bus they already had it shopped in
half and tear it apart in the middle of
scene that's all real Wow things are
robot going through it yeah Wow
something that's helping Michael Bay hey
he's putting the camera in a realistic
place it's very grounded you're in a car
you're in chase cam you know yeah you're
seeing it from these angles that's so
cool it's a huge challenge of that
though is you're literally filming
something that's not there see if they
have what we call our CG goggles they're
down your CG goggles on if he imagining
that robot coming through when I pressed
his tackled they're right here it's like
slightly out of frame it feels flawed in
a real way I don't think people gave
Michael Bay meant a good technical
filming
[Music]
this is Arthur worked on this movie
that's true hey sorry here watching the
bear scene from the revenant and we're
wondering dude or was like thanks for
the metric up when you have a cut from
one piece to another but an element in
the footage is basically in the same
like in 2001 the bone turns into a
spaceship but this also be a visual
effects technique or basically magic
where you know you're doing bass like a
whip pan and right in the middle that
whip you're just match cutting
all right there.these the flashes a lot
of these different stunts require very
specific setups that you can't do with
and what they're doing here like alright
so super sensitive to motion where we
don't really read details in them so I
wipe in the frame that many wipes the
frame there rotoscoping the edge of him
so everything gets reveals and wipes is
from the next shot but something to have
hidden costs nothing to have the
intricacy of this puzzle of a fight
scene we're doing all these tricks and
taking advantage of those taking cuts
wait a minute wait a minute is that
located a horse jump this is actually a
treasure trove of amazing oh there's
something very special about this shot
there is the actor has legs by the way
so there's one very very small thing
that they did here that helps sell
legs Clint did you see it yeah so if the
actor has his legs which I assume he
does then how does he swipe his legs
yeah exactly so here's what I think did
that table wasn't there when they filmed
Gary Sinise because notice he never
actually interacts with the table watch
the table
Gary Sinise has liked I don't think so
I've watched CSI New York home thanks
again doesn't have one excellent that's
a really realistic table feels like it's
not really there really like drives on
the fact that like this character does
not have legs
all right so this one Peter Parker here
gone back in time he's got that like
that a Dirac lead to be herself can you
show he's basically Rodney and Bruce
arises introducing them to modern
America she's embarrassed that she's
becoming colorized if she's becoming
modernized a modern woman but she
doesn't want her husband to see her that
way so she needs to have her face so it
was like is he like putting on that
green screen makeup so I'm making all
the green screen 'candy saturating it
and that's all they're doing but Leslie
saturated that you can do this in
DaVinci Resolve yeah I don't know how
they do this the world is black and
white how do they get yellow light to
shine on the characters and things in
the world
all right so yellow and the fence there
you see that yellow light on the black
the black and white tree has yellow
light
[Music]
but already I think I know this it's
gonna be like so how is there some sort
of like lens filter that can't see a
certain shade of makeup how do you know
how they change this it's just a red and
blue filter just like when you have like
3d glasses right in the red side doesn't
let you see the red lines the blue side
doesn't see the blue lines you save a
red filter from the camera and it's
filtering out any red on her so you know
my colors red marks on her face you
can't see that you transition to a blue
filter and suddenly all those red
splotches to come right and you can see
all the luminous done let's go to black
and white now let's just show only the
blue channel because colors may have a
brand green and blue channels so we show
only the blue Channel
this should look relatively dark and
there's nothing about to think right now
we flip it over we go only to the red
Channel right channels values the
greatest thing they're doing these crazy
for all intents and purposes visual
effects but they don't have the same
sort of I saw when they fixed that I did
see that quarter cruise is a great
channel I've seen their deep fakes for
the Tom Cruise one the John with the
count rousillon want all their different
videos on like stunts and yeah action
they didn't want about like guns and
muzzle flashes and how all the silencer
scenes you see in movies are completely
unreal yeah I love what they do because
they actually work on like real things
too yeah they're not just like film
students or something like that doing
this like they they really know what
they're doing and I like the experiments
and I feel like these guys could be like
huge oscar-winning VFX artists down the
road oh yeah one they've I mean this
series for them I think is relatively
new cuz the corridor crew has been
around for a little while but I just I
love this recent string of YouTube
videos were like professionals react to
things yeah well they've been hitting
the trending page an awful lot CGI is a
huge part of our world I'm not at all
surprised that this is one of the most
popular of these series very throwing up
so quickly because I remember when the
first one dropped
or just blew up right away well they're
so funny - it's like why are you guys in
front of the camera more computers
should be doing more there's a top
comment here though that I found from a
woman named Lucinda de la Li we tried
IMD being her in the middle of a jump
cut couldn't find her this is like a
highly upvoted vu coming I worked on
Pleasantville the burning tree scene are
all shot in black and white Oh in your
home base mr. Durden is not shot in
black and white we had a poly over the
fence and with proprietary software then
pulled out yellow on one luminance level
I know exactly all the words she's using
and the longshots yellow on the house
was done the same the tree was in the
same way within more complicated poly
over the fire a little smoke and several
different luminance levels pulled in
different you know what about you guys
just go and read it because I don't know
what but I got from it was it was shot
in black and white that's all I got
everything else I'm like nope don't
understand what you're telling me
they've been told just like shades of
light and and slight color from the fire
or something but that movie has always
been a fascinating sort of Marvel I
remember watching back in the day the
making of and all the different ways in
which they achieved the effects in that
movie because some of it was gray makeup
some of it was like they said here green
makeup and yeah one of my favorites
actually though that I've wanted to try
for a long time is the black and white
one cuz that's a trick I kind of noticed
in old horror movies back in the day and
was always mystified by when you put on
like red or green makeup and then you
change the lighting to bring it out like
a transformation or you change the
filter or something like that really
kind of mind-blowing when you first see
it tricks that's so old-school you know
that you know it's always kind of
impressive
I'm sure the face app will be able to
yeah help us out with doing that and a
much smoother way yeah and this
complicated switching our red and blue
light who needs ingenuity like guys here
I'll help you out right now oh this is
face number one and now with the face
app see VFX quarter through oh no
nothing
face saps guys you've nailed down it
still shocks me how bad the yeah and the
claws and then when they slow it down
yeah it's even worse than I remember
weirdest sparks and the lack of shadows
they just seemed see it worse and worse
as every year goes by is that was like
such a popular I remember watching that
in the theaters going oh god I look so
bad yeah that specific scene looks so
awful and it looked really bad in the
trailers too and we're all like no no
they're just not finished and then we
saw the movie and now they were finished
yeah or at least as finished as they
were willing to do I knew there was like
a writer's strike going on with there
that having anything to do on the visual
effects and that's unless it was the
kind of thing where they just added it
last minute I can't imagine it would
have had any effect of a visual Navy
slowed down a lot of the movements they
don't track well with his hands like the
claws man it's pretty awful but you know
the Patrick sturdy aging I think for its
time is not terrible it looks bad but
it's not terrible for its time but if
there are some movies today that do
de-aging you're like that's about on par
with Coulson and Captain Marvel honestly
you know somebody had to be one of the
early you know adopters somebody had to
test this out first yeah you know go
there so that we could all look back and
really think of far we've come I mean
x-men was like the first one to try it
out right with x-men 3 if they're really
just try to get on Patrick Stewart and
Orson so let's do one more time pull it
off that was the first time I really
remember people making a huge deal out
of it anyway it's crazy to see these
guys really defend Michael Bay here
there's this video and on the Patrick H
Williams channel he has a two-parter
about Michael Bay as an on tour I love
Michael Bay now because there are a lot
of great thing pieces that are like this
guy doesn't necessarily make thoughtful
or quality films but you can really
break down his style in a definitive way
and when it comes to at least stuff like
this you know you got to give him props
because yeah the the blend of what's
practical and what is CG and how I
handled the CG is pretty great in these
transformers movies like it's the shame
that they go to bolster whatever those
scripts are
you know I like what they talk about
with the match cutting because the match
cutting is is a specific tool that a lot
of filmmakers use to make things look
like one-shots - especially nowadays
there's the famous daredevil season 1
fight scene in the hallway I feel like
there's no match cuts there but there's
the season 2 fight scene where he's he
goes down the stairwell like it's a much
longer fight there's obvious moments
where they're passing through the camera
like they were they pointed out in
Kingsman when you have someone passed in
front of the camera or you do a quick
kind of whip pan you can easily do a cut
in there and make it look like it's Paul
we've even done that but yeah like
little silly sketches we've done to make
it look like it's part of one shot so
it's cool they pointed it out because it
is like probably the most common type of
trick to use to make things look like
they're one cut yeah one especially we
have with just the popularity of one
takes now and still haven't done it's
funny cuz you know sometimes you can see
where the shots are married together and
sometimes you really really can't feel
like if I pay attention to it I usually
can't the Kingsmen ones are very hard
like that even when they were watching
it in this format I have a hard time
seeing it you're like really slowing it
down I can't even tell where you're
cutting it honestly yeah it's - its -
flawless these guys are awesome they're
hilarious and this is a channel where
you really learned a lot Cinna fix you
learn like storytelling and directing
and all that here you learn like a bag
oh yeah you and learn wide variety of
film school that's available on YouTube
yeah it's fun and - like for as much as
there's bickering over practical versus
CG effects I think this stuff actually
helps us to get a better sense for
what's going on in a better appreciation
of the art style and just what happens
to make the movies that we see cuz
there's so much stuff in movies you
would never realize the CG alright guys
well make sure to subscribe at the core
core crew youtube channel click their
notification bell you can do that for us
if you want it's really your choice I'm
not gonna force you into anything that
would be assault
Cameron French thanks man for requesting
this video we did a Q&A recently at our
patreon page that was asking about what
our favorite wrestler entrances are and
theme songs and then Cameron decided to
link 20 entrances diff
two wrestlers for me just to check out
and watch on my own time it's got a lot
of time on his hands right now that's
why you're one of the best people in the
world dude because you go the extra mile
I love you for things like that you're
always sending me [ __ ] 9.5 times out of
10 I'll check it out I'm gonna make time
this weekend to go through all of those
entrances I can't believe I'm putting
myself out there like that dude just
just put them on while you're at the gym
that's good okay I'll be I'll be watch I
gotta watch them it's not just songs
there's entrances motivation motivation
motivation they're all fat wrestlers I
don't want to be any of them one of
them's gotta be buff they're all fat all
right throw fat they're all fat oops